hi there guys my name is Bob Evans key
I'm a filmmaker musician I'm located in
New York City and I'm here to talk about
my latest project which was the music
video to the song sex I'm going to be
covering topics like what camera we use
what lenses we use how did I research
how did a searcher look what inspired me
to do that music video first of all I
would like to start with location was
shouted at they the really really small
studio was a widescreen which would try
to make look bigger not even try to make
it look bigger but we had to shoot
variety of shots in a really small space
and make them look much different so we
focused on a lot of close-ups that's a
great trick if you have a really small
space you can focus on close-ups so
focused on close-ups we're focused on
body shots on dance break and I realized
I knew that it's going to be a lot of
surface of face and it's house has to be
high-quality something but we didn't
have money for we didn't have a budget
we didn't have money for great locations
or anything else so we decided to go if
you want a budget we decided to go with
a camera Canon 7d which is a great
camera not expensive at all if you use
it right Canon 7d does not really shoot
in doesn't doesn't have an option to
shoot a raw footage but my DP was really
smart guy and he decided to go with this
device it called ninja I believe you can
buy it online on Amazon for like $300 or
rent one or just buy one and then return
for your shoot if you in a budget again
and so basically what it does you
connected to a camera and footage on its
way through the wire to a external
recorder from a camera this nature is
like catches roll footage and doesn't
let it go doesn't doesn't doesn't
doesn't let it go smaller doesn't let it
just does not transform it to any kind
of different format in easy words yeah
so I had this big raw footage files
which is so much better for color
correction
it's just a better quality everything
better it's takes project takes a video
to a new level
if you use it right you have to
definitely research how to do it better
to work with a DP who used to work with
ninja who used to do this kind of trick
but you can achieve great results doing
it I researched it a lot for my music
video I think the best way to research
is just to look other people work and a
good work um people watch videos look at
the music video if it has a good amount
of use look what kind of shells I used
so I I wanted something really
provocative I wanted something straight
lines kind of look I did not want video
to look busy
I knew that video is going to be focused
on three people me dancer and an actress
so it's have to be a straight lines in a
video it cannot be destructed by
anything else
if you watch a video you understand what
I'm talking about um so I just watched a
bunch of videos on YouTube different
kind of bands famous artists I try to
make it look different so I researched a
lot of independent artists in South
Africa all over the world because
current artists tend to try really hard
I think and they have a lot of money to
try really hard so if you don't have a
lot of money you have to you have to you
have to have a concept you have to I
think that camera choice is one of the
most important choices before filming
anything I would say my top 3 camera
choices would be Canon 70d second and 7d
sorry black magic they just came out
with a new one and uh old fashioned
canon marks Reedy which is great camera
if you use it right again there's a
great range of everything great quality
and really really easy to use black
magic it's one of the best cameras I
would have having to work with if you
would compare it to the red I love I'm a
filmmaker I came from a classic
filmmaking school and
black magic give you that film look no
matter what you should you can shoot a
finger I get you the lamb and it's going
to look like in a movie
it just has something something in it I
would say if you compare it to a red
which is really famous camera and a lot
of people spend so much money to shoot
on red it gives you kind of like this
great quality you can see every every
every every every piece of hair in a
video but it would not look as cinematic
as black magic so it's also much free
top camera choices which all of them all
three of them really affordable any
black magic I believe you can buy for
five thousand dollars not necessarily
have to buy you can rent one if you
would choose buy or rent a camera I
think I always rent I try to use
different cameras I for instance my to
go camera is Canon 60d it's just
something to have it some some what I'm
filming with right now let's give you a
great quality it's give you a full
resolution if you use light right if you
sound right it made ads all those
capabilities it's not as good for
particular projects to research your
camera you know I use a lot Amazon you
know when they have a best-seller for
some reason it is a best-seller for some
reason people like it and people who
would spend that much money for a camera
would not would not not know what they
buying so those are not regular people
those are professionals I use a lot of
videos on YouTube when people test
cameras it's a greatest way when they
compare cameras it's takes a while but I
would say Amazon and YouTube first of
all I think you have to have a budget in
mind you have to have a budget what if
you if you rent in a cake are you
willing to spend $50 or $250 I willing
to spend $500 or $1000 right if you want
to rent where you're willing to spend
the same time and based on your budget
based on my budget for instant in my
example I would go online and it would
see what cameras in that budget using
Amazon for
to find a price and once I found a price
I find that camera online on YouTube
most likely is going to be some kind of
really famous camera and I'll say with
other people professionals have to do
with it what they do did they test it
what happened I put a lot of time into
research right now I'm really good at it
I do it all the time I would say it
would take me I usually take it kind of
in sessions I can research for an hour
and a half and then again I would say 2
to 3 hours in general doesn't take
really long especially with videos on
youtubes also perfect way perfect source
of finding something I think that the
most important factor into choosing a
camera right camera for shoot would be
what kind of look you're going for what
are you trying to do are you trying to
do a cinematic look that's what I
appreciate the most all the time or are
you looking for something more glamorous
by glamorous I mean really really high
definition kind of you want to see each
detail of a goal was red red epic red
one even old version anything
the best way to understand is to look
other videos and how other filmmakers
manage to you that camera what do they
do
so most of the time honestly it's it's
about what you have already most of the
time might be already have a camera if I
work as an UDP so that's just what you
use I don't think that I think in with a
lie with the right fashion location you
can achieve much better results a camera
here's an advice camera does not define
a concept camera does not define a
location camera does not define live in
camera does not define your script or
your art so I a lot of people think if
they're going to invest a lot of money
in a camera they're gonna have a dough
project [ __ ] they not because you
can you can really go with them with
something as easy as canon 7d and have a
great results if you use it right is it
use it right and honestly I have a lot
of advice because I never had
huge budget had good enough budget or no
budget and that's why I learned a lot of
skills how to how'd you be able to
achieve great look by taking a cheap
camera and use it smart using different
devices
it's just something which you have to
research additionally all lenses very
important we're important to use a right
lens they have a lot of cinematic lenses
I don't know don't remember all the
names but those are big ones and lens is
really really important but it's kind of
like good quality images combination of
a body of a camera and the lens together
if you're a really really good body for
camera honestly any lens would do as
long as a good enough lens and you can a
lens with you because you have if you
have really bad body of a camera but
great Lance it's this great lens by
capturing light correctly will save your
footage we'll make it look so much more
better than it could be uh in terms of
Landis I just think of a shots I think
which shots I write a storyboard or just
write in a notes
what would shots how do you envision
them if I know I'll be using close-ups
I'll look at the lands I look at the
close-ups for instance I can use like
some Justin Bieber video or any any kind
of video of those artists out there for
his money and I would go online I would
look at those videos I would send a
screenshot to my DP director of
photography if you don't know what I'm
saying and he would tell me oh I think
they used 80 millimeters with a shot or
something else and I'm like okay great
and we try to think what lens they used
and usually for close-ups 80 millimeter
I think that's the best game it makes
your face look so good thank you very
much for watching this interview and
which my music video on my youtube
channel well Britain's Kissin and yeah I
hope I helped you somehow in order for
you to actually the best results
possible for your future project and
good luck